water filled auto filled auto filled
water filled oh my god look at that look
at the train
[Music]
this is all the commission so we've
already spent like 300
of commission
today we're going to be building a
trading bot that lets twitch chat
trade a thousand dollars of my personal
money
you might be wondering wait the title
says 25
000 what gives well initially
i wanted to only trade a thousand
dollars but i ran into issues where it
forced me
to put 25 000 into my account
you'll see why later what better way
is there to get closer to my subscribers
than to let them manage my money
okay let's start to build this we need
to create a twitch bot that listens to
messages
and whenever someone writes a command
like sell apple
or buy gme it will route the request
to our other bot that will connect to
the stock trading api
and execute the orders that's it it's
pretty easy
is it yeah yeah it is it was not
now i did a ton of research on various
trading platforms
and i believe that interactive brokers
would be the best
fit that was also untrue
so i registered for an account answered
a bunch of questions about my trading
experience
registered a cool ass username
and now all i have to do is put a
thousand dollars into this account
i feel like this is a great time to talk
about drama class
i'm trying out this new platform that
allows me to offer a ton of free videos
for you guys and also now this was
highly requested you can buy
a single course and keep it forever if
you don't want to subscribe
and pay every month if you don't care
about the other videos
so go ahead try it out if you like it
feel free to purchase it or subscribe
all right back to the video
all right perfect so i wired the money
and now i have to wait a few days for it
to clear
so we can play with the platform so i'll
see you in a couple of days
[Music]
okay money is in let's uh open up the
trading platform
cool cool i have no idea what any of
this
is let's watch a tutorial
[Music]
wow trading is so cool let's play this
again
[Music]
anyways the first thing we'll do is try
to write a program
to buy and sell stocks through code
instead of using the interface
and to do that we'll use their api
[Applause]
[Music]
okay great when we run this program it's
supposed to buy one stock of apple
let's see if this works
okay great when we run this program it's
supposed to buy one stock of apple
let's see if this works
autofilled perfect
worked on my first try awesome
now we have to create a twitch bot uh
what we'll do is get the official code
sample
from twitch devs make sure i understand
it before i copy it
[Music]
i know some of these words okay
all right now i get my access token
change the channel name print out the
messages to make sure it works
oh excellent as you can see on the right
it's on the terminal let's do a few more
all right cool that works um well let's
now
try to let's now connect the two uh so
the twitch chat can buy and sell stocks
all right cool montage time
[Music]
all right so um we have a problem
um i woke up this morning and my account
was locked
so i i tried inputting some orders and i
got an error saying
order rejected reason potential
pattern day trade so apparently a
pattern day trader is someone who buys
and sells a particular stock
in the same trading day which is what i
was doing when i was testing
my code and even if i'm not testing i
would want my followers
to be able to buy and sell the same
stock within the same trading day
because it's more fun it's more
interactive
but apparently it's it's a rule by the
sec
that if you want to day trade you need
the account to maintain
at least 25 000
and 25 000 is a lot of money
like i don't i don't really know
what what i'll do
hello yeah that's me yeah i'm okay
you uh-huh yeah
so it's possible would i get double if i
sell both my kidneys
oh you can't
i see okay
all right all right so today is the day
we're going to let the public test it
out and play with my 25
dollars as you can see i got tws
opened up and i got my graph here that i
made
as you can see it just fills it fills
the void
yeah that's cool all right let's go live
autofilled
[Music]
don't go too crazy it's
actually whatever who cares okay so
basically you guys
um you guys can see here these are all
the
uh trades that happened and then this is
your chat
this is the news i don't know it's not
that important
and then this is your portfolio this is
what you have all right
the goal is to be able to be
to get a positive return during this
test run we didn't run into any
technical difficulties
surprisingly it worked as intended and
people were buying and selling stocks
however i did notice that my profits
kept declining
and that was because of commission this
is why interactive brokers might not
have been the best choice
since they charge a minimum of a dollar
per trade
or a max of one percent of the value
traded
i thought about creating a voting system
where people can vote on which stock to
buy or sell
every five minutes and after that the
top voted action gets executed
unfortunately i think that's kind of
boring you don't get to see your trade
immediately executed because all you can
do is vote
people need to feel like they're
contributing in real time right
and and it's satisfying when um when the
moment you place your order it gets
executed so you get that immediate
feedback it's so fun it's it's it's what
twitch live is all about right so i
think i decided
that i'll enable trading for just 30
minutes
a day where they can go crazy and i'll
just eat the cost
whatever because that's just more fun
and also how many orders can he possibly
place
in 30 minutes yeah i think that's what
i'll do
[Music]
order filled order filled and you have
to you have to start selling guys you
have to start selling
you have to start selling all right
let's sell google we have too much
google
for we have eight tesla seven teslas
five
s and dl i don't know what that is for
abc's
[Music]
okay we're going to stop it now abort
autofilled
oh all right good job guys
i hope you had fun wow look at all this
look at all this all right
share your script i want to lose money
to be honest we actually did pretty well
i mean the only reason why we lost so
much money right now is just because of
the commission if we don't take
commission into account
i'm pretty sure we didn't do that bad
you know we're buying like normal stocks
i guess
whoever whoever bought melly m-e-l-i
we just made 2.8 percent on that trade
right so that's pretty cool oh we're
making money
on nvidia we made 12.95
so after all the commission and stuff if
you guys look
dude we're making we're making profit
like it's going up and then maybe next
year on my next birthday i can show you
guys uh how much you guys
made how much we made together as a
as a team so to be honest to be honest
our portfolio is not that diverse
our portfolio is only amazon nvidia
google tesla and basically these are
tech companies it's it's not that out of
a question that we're going to be
where we're going to make a profit in a
year the reason is because we're just
tech stocks basically we're invested in
tech companies
and it's because and it's because you
guys just
you guys are in tech so so the only
stocks you guys know are
are tech stocks and also because they're
expensive so they take most of the
portfolio yeah man you guys you guys are
the best you know joma capital
or joma subscribers capital or jomof
thank you for uh investing with me
and i'll see you in a year to see uh how
much money we've made
but yeah i thank you for all the
birthday wishes you guys are
you guys are very nice you know a great
start to my day
i just woke up by the way i woke up at
12 today aka two hours ago
but yeah all right have a great day guys
[Music]
jomo what are you doing on twitch justin
just
justin khan co-founder of twitch where
are you facetiming me for
i'm going to be honest with you you
should probably stick to youtube
it's a little bit embarrassing that you
have no views even with 25k on the line
well i think you
should stick to just being a vc it's
kind of embarrassing how small your
youtube channel is
dude that's so bit so mean
so you want to collab sure let's do it